[Music]
have you guys ever woken up in [ __ ] yeah
wait that's a baby woke up in [ __ ] yeah
is it your own or is it a dog Bart [ __ ]
yes I'm a B C's for woke up and Bart
[ __ ] yeah I remember pooping the bed
when I was like three I let everyone
down one time one time guys when I was
when I had a babysitter when I used to
go to my roosters and Gardena I was like
I think I was like I was like I was like
eight and then um I had a poo really bad
but my babysitter's son jason he was in
the bathroom was like I [ __ ] hate
Jason ah dude no Jason was a nice guy
okay I had to pull really bad and he was
in their house like Jason at the poo and
he was like I'm pooping I was like oh
man and I felt it like go go down my
butthole in some I like my pant leg yeah
that moment of surrender yeah cuz I was
like I wasn't all of the negative moment
where you're like do I just like relax
it just let it all come out or do I try
to still fight it no I wasn't trying to
fight have you ever pooped in your car
of course yeah right so yeah I once I I
want I'm diary to my car pretty hard I
have no and let me tell you something
Wow at that point at that point I like I
was on Google Maps and it's at 45
minutes till home and I was like this is
a medical emergency and so why did you
just pull over I couldn't I was gone I
was a major freeway then everyone's
heard of yeah pull over
he was in the carpool lane just [ __ ] on
the side you can't you can't public
indecency I'm not a sad I won't be a
registered sex offender mark I went in
wait tell me what happened I want to
know what happened okay so yeah I how
does that options guys I was oh I'm so
sorry
no yeah thank you and so yeah ultimately
I didn't let it go I fought it as hard
as I could
well we like rocky want I couldn't go
the distance
and yeah it all just kind of came out me
and then that moment what did you face
and no is Rocky one he was king and what
my what a my face to it was whole
surrendered my come face yeah is no but
I surrendered and at that point you know
you feel in the back of your legs you
feel it all over the [ __ ] place that
you're just like wait you drove all the
way home I know this is wait we drove
all the way back home
I drove always like pull over and all
the way back home this way before Nikki
okay for once in your life I bet you
wished your windbreaker pants you could
come to Kate in inside I wish it had
that elastic around the ankle that
elastic around the ankle is worth its
weight in gold in moments like that yeah
did you get out the car with your legs
oh no I just did that walk over
yeah the waddle and your neighbor comes
out hey Steve how's it going you
actually take it like stewed things in
your mail now no okay so the reason why
I ask is because this chick named Abby
she tweeted this is what she looks like
first of all she [ __ ] herself oh hey
good thing she's hot cuz she [ __ ]
herself well her makeup so there's no
her makeup is nice it's good beat I
actually don't like her makeup is it you
know you hadn't you're enjoying her
makeup if I'm being 100 as a as a pants
[ __ ] I don't like I feel like her
little her contour here is nice agree
and I think that she the the upper eye
is a little too smoky it's all smoky for
you maybe she just came back from a
night out on the town with the ladies it
has a reptilian look I agree I'm
surprised you don't like this look cuz
you like like really hookers like trashy
looks I do but I'm not calling her trash
I like her little highlight on the inner
inner inner life
yeah highlight looks cool he likes that
American Gypsy Wedding look I do like
that okay what about Abby
anyway tweeted this out her dogs
she said men and protects combo that
says man man she says why have I just
woken up with [ __ ] all over me in my bed
sheet I question mark
I left you some chalky stars I put them
on your face while you were sleeping
what was the thought process behind that
I don't get it's chocolate it's talking
about her face while you pack your [ __ ]
story for no [ __ ] reason I remember
that no I've never told this it was a
private but I definitely have not hold
on yeah you have it you were thinking
about running for president man I can't
man what did you see what this place
does to you it won't help your campaign
no awal going to [ __ ]
what are you done to him I [ __ ] myself
he is human man I sharted on a golf
course once for you yeah and then what
happened what's on it okay proud I was
playing a little 18 holes I used to take
lessons golf lessons and there was like
a little mini tournament and I remember
um I was uh no not mini golf it was a
little tournament but it was like the
girls are real behind golf lessons 15
minutes no like
and I it was one of those what you think
you're just gonna fart and it becomes a
shart oh and I think I was on like the
tenth hole so I still had some holes to
go and and it was I was far from any
like bathrooms you know I'm saying and I
just remember like butch of a golf cart
you can get out I was in the car I
started I got into the car and I was
kind of like you know and I was like and
I I thought I was gonna be okay but I
wasn't and and I remember I think I was
like wearing like shorts
but luckily like what everything no no
no but then not when you're like out and
about yes boxer briefs I think I was
away I think I was my boxer briefs oh
thank god kind of contain DNA Tim did
you finish what you started I can't
believe you built the business office I
liked it make your money off the [ __ ] in
our Barry Singh moments yeah that was
that was one the last times I really
remember like [ __ ] myself yeah yeah
that's tragic
yeah well have you guys ever woken up
with food in your bed as a child I woke
up with gum in my hair so many like when
you fall asleep drunk and you wake
oh my god you remember a few years ago
nose digging the protein shakes I like
that story I would fall asleep on the
couch and for some reason and then
protein shake and I would fell asleep
until I spilled it all over the couch
all over myself and then look like dried
up [ __ ] all over the have you ever woke
up next to one that you didn't recognize
and then you're like oh [ __ ] that's
actually my wife and then you're like oh
[ __ ]
good thing I didn't say that out loud no
he asked and you didn't answer so I'll
stress if you're gonna answer it I was
gonna see if you're looking in it I'm
just trying to further my political
career yeah what are you done no yeah so
I remember one time I got really [ __ ]
up and then I woke up the next day and I
was like oh my god what the [ __ ] cuz I
had a horrible nightmare that I had
cheated on Nicki and then I woke up and
was like oh my god is it real because
for some reason it didn't look like
Nikki cuz her mouth was open a lot and
then when I from the midden I just hit
me that you know okay I'm good yeah
close their mouth me like oh god yeah
it's her it's still her I think I know I
had so many nightmares around the 10
that we were engaged that I was with my
ex again like somehow like with like
what are the two exes like they wouldn't
be entertained herbal and I would awake
that would rotate like that yeah my
dreams like I'd be with like one X and
then the other dream would be with the
owner other X but the point is I was
with my exes and all with Kasey and I
would wake up like oh my god how did
this happen and then I wake up like all
cases were they that's my nightmare
every time two of them make it wait no
not the same title but were you doing
bad activities or is it like a
pharmaceutical commercial you're flying
kites or something it was neither it was
me like living my old life and you guys
are fly fishing it's always fishing
why is it always like because it's super
into fly fish now really man if you if
you get them started that pole will
start talking for like an hour about
fly-fishing
huh what's the difference between
regular fishing yeah well the whole
thing is I guess it's it's a fly that
they you have to mimic its active mimic
bugs do you like making it yeah so they
make them like the whole fun part is
that they make the bugs and then they
have to study how the flies go yeah and
that's why they do that I don't that cuz
at the end it's like it's literally a
fly and then to me like catching the
fish they fly no same [ __ ] as people who
paint Dungeons and Dragons figures
literally at like it's the same [ __ ] I
did not know about what that meant fly
fishing like that same [ __ ] so I'm gonna
mimic a fly no I'm gonna go by a little
tiny fly yeah looks like a fly I'll give
them like a little orange humble-bee
one's a fly they have the difference one
mosquito seems [ __ ] like that
well you're like why do you care this
much and oh I'm gonna pee - [ __ ] look
pretty cool and then they have the what
is it called the [ __ ] tool kit box
the tackle box yeah and they have all
their different bait [ __ ] now that's cuz
they hand make it yeah yeah they're
weird
it's pretty funny my dad was not weird
he was kind of fly fishing he would do
all sorts of fishing all sorts listen
fishing his way manlier than D&D I'll
give you that but at the end of the day
they're very similar as far as
fly-fishing five fish who's old who did
win his old know when it was cool he
played pool for some reason when you
become a certain age you think
fly-fishing is like bitching
yeah like over 60 yeah this is fun
fishing spot but flying fish but like D
by that fishing is fine it's not fun
it's boring as [ __ ] um all these guys
like to do it so not fishies kind of fun
fishies got fun in bodies boy together
doing it yeah listen somebody who [ __ ]
their pants let me tell you something as
a fact fishing is kind of fun I [ __ ] my
pants too and it's not that fun how hard
did you shoot yourself pretty hard
that's I ask you what face you make cuz
my face was like in disbelief I was like
that's a lot of [ __ ] were you wearing a
thong we were in leggings with the
pooping did you have legging privilege
it's never that type of [ __ ] when you
have to [ __ ] really bad it's never the
solidus Aliki butts oh thank you but we
were did you have legging perfect
perfect no I did it I was in business
cuz she was a businesswoman [ __ ]
herself
oh this is when you were still at the
bay yeah yeah yeah it's a business
transaction
did you have a cap on it no
[Laughter]